less than six months ago the World
Health Organization declared the Ebola
outbreak and international public health
emergency it might surprise you to hear
that the number of new Ebola cases has
dropped below a hundred per week so what
happened how did we go from the largest
and most complex of bola outbreak in
history to almost total containment in
just half a year more than 8500 people
have died from this Ebola epidemic a
huge and tragic number of victims but
that is tens of thousands short of the
number that the Centers for Disease
Control said could fall victim to the
disease 1.4 million people could be
infected by early next year 1.4 million
point 4 million people but 1.4 million
referred to the projected number of
deaths if no steps were taken to curb
the disease the CDC also predicted that
was sufficient intervention Ebola would
be quote almost ended by January 20th
2015 and that's exactly what happened
the most effective intervention to
slowing Ebola spread was something
pretty simple educating the public
billboards banners and text messages
about how to avoid infection blanketed
western Africa the public learned to
avoid crowded places schools were closed
and elections were canceled and perhaps
most importantly medical practice has
changed ensuring that there was minimal
contact when handling bodies and
performing burials so what about the
international response it would be wrong
to say that the global community didn't
help curb the Ebola epidemic but due to
the slow response time of governments
around the world many of those efforts
didn't gain momentum until December when
things in West Africa were already
starting to turn around
you